the two senate runoff elections in
georgia are heating up republican
incumbent
incumbent kelly lefler called democratic
challenger
rafael warnock a radical liberal in a
debate last night
he said she lied on jesus by misquoting
from his sermons
in the second debate democrat jon ossoff
was alone
on stage after republican senator david
perdue
refused to take part president trump led
a rally for lefleur and purdue on
saturday
and repeated his false claim that the
presidential election was rigged
before the rally he urged georgia's
republican governor brian kemp
to convene a special legislative session
to overturn the election
kemp and lieutenant governor jeff duncan
issued a joint statement last night
after some other georgia republicans
called for legislators
to name new electors kemp and duncan
said that
would be illegal and lieutenant governor
jeff duncan joins us now lieutenant
governor
good morning to you over the weekend you
said you were concerned
by the president's continued attacks
baseless attacks on the election
and disgusted by the security threats
that have followed those attacks
i'm curious what was your breaking point
well look for five weeks we've been
working hard here to count every single
legal vote here in georgia
it has been unbelievable to see the
mountains of misinformation continue to
fly in
from every angle literally stuff that
can be debunked in 10 seconds or less
and so yeah we're focused on making sure
we follow the letter of the law
lieutenant governor
can you really say when you talk about
these mountains of misinformation and i
appreciate your focus on following the
law
your colleague governor rafson or
secretary of state raffensberger has
been doing
the same are you really surprised by
this behavior from the president given
that he has cast out on the election
before
the votes were cast and all the way back
to 2016 he was calling it rigged i mean
can you really say
this is out of character well my focus
right now
is that we make sure we have a very fair
legal election but also to get senator
lefler purdue reelected on january 5th
there is no scenario that i can see that
it's helpful for the mountains of
misinformation around election fraud
in helping to turn out the vote on
january 5th my focus and my
encouragement to the president
to his team and to the senators trying
to run for re-election
that they realigned their focus on
getting re-elected
governor there respectfully there are
bigger things at stake here than just
one election cycle we're talking about
attacks on democracy itself
and we're talking about threats to the
safety of people alive and well
today when you think about the
president's behavior
here and now it's unfortunate that the
spotlight is on you and your colleagues
there in the state of georgia
do you regret not speaking up when the
president was attacking
others in this way endangering their
safety do you
wish you had done something sooner so
that you and your colleagues were not in
this situation now
well i'm not certain of the basis of
your question i've been i'll tell you
the basis i'll tell you the basis
mr lieutenant governor the president
attacks dozens of people
a year on twitter and in many cases
mayors governors
senators members of congress everyday
citizens members of the news media they
then need security because the president
has stirred up his supporters
and kind of stick them on them that's
the basis of my question republicans did
not speak up
over four years of this happening now
it's happening to republicans
do you regret now that you've seen what
what it feels like not speaking up
sooner that's the basis
well i think there's a great opportunity
for us to pivot here as as republicans
you know
gop 2.0 has got to include a better way
to message
you know 280 characters on twitter is
not a way to message
uh to america and certainly we've got an
opportunity to to
to your point i think america as a whole
wants uh
leaders that that are inspiring and not
condescending
uh you know i've got three boys i'm
trying to raise that's certainly the
message i want to drive home with them
each and every day and
you know i'm one of those folks that has
added security because of the the
current conditions we're in it's not fun
uh it's not it's not uh it's not not
american to be honest with you the words
and the disparaging comments that
continue to fly in we're better than
this
this is america do you regret i'm sorry
gail i just if you're saying it's not
american and this is a person you voted
for
twice president trump he's stirring this
up
do you regret that vote and what do you
want other republicans to do now
to contain what is a deeply problematic
situation for our society
yeah i want us to focus on january 5th
here in georgia
this isn't only a big deal for us for
republicans in georgia this is a big
deal for republicans all over the
country
as we focus in on trying i think it's
important to understand georgia's
politics are such
we've got eight statewide constitutional
republican officers we've got
republican majorities in the state
senate and the state house this is a
conservative state
and we've got to make sure that we send
those folks back to the polls on january
5th
on election day an interesting statistic
to understand
53.7 percent of folks in georgia voted
for a republican state senator
that's an important number to make sure
that that folks that are talking about
you know the misinformation around
election fraud
53.7 percent of folks voted for a
republican for the state senate that's
that's a very big number lieutenant
governor duncan i think you're right
when you say it's not american we are
better than this i think your three boys
can be proud that you were at least
trying to put out the correct
information out there i watched the
whole two-hour rally
with my mouth was hanging open and the
thing that i want you to address
again it has been asked and answered he
played this tape
jeff where you see somebody bringing out
a suitcase that he says or
boats and that they're doing something
tricky with the votes could you please
explain you said it can be cleared up in
10 seconds
could you please explain again what
people are looking at and explain why
this is there's nothing nefarious
happening here
yeah i think the secretary of state's
office did an incredible job of
explaining this
he keeps playing tape well look i i
can't change somebody's mind
but i can certainly continue to separate
fact from fiction and that's really the
process we're in
is separating fact from fiction and
moving on it's certainly not helpful
as i said earlier in the interview
there's no scenario where this makes
sense to help
kelly lefler and david perdue get
elected and nobody was pulling out
ballots underneath the table
and counting them is the point i'm
trying to make here yeah absolutely it's
it's
it's unfortunate that folks all right
simple yes and no because we do have to
go
do you think it's time for the 200
members of congress who have yet to
recognize
the outcome of this election to step up
and say it's over
joe biden is going to be sworn in as the
46th president on january 20th and it
will still be america and we will still
have the constitution
and we'll still have a vigorous debate
about policy in the ongoing years
lieutenant governor duncan thank you
very much
thank you